joy your new book is all about Trump's
impact on America do you think we'll be
able to recover from his presidency once
he finally leaves office I keep saying
he never will well you know what he
keeps saying he never will right now
he's doing it you know it's gonna be
very hard I interviewed a lot of people
from all around the world who all said
one thing the thing that America has
said about itself since World War two we
kind of suspect it might be a bit
[ __ ] Donald Trump has made us feel
yep it was always [ __ ] we don't
believe it anymore
so getting the world to believe again to
believe that we are the good people the
good people the leader of the free world
real democracy the multicultural
democracy I think that went pretty far
down after Vietnam he's created it and
the other thing is it's like supply
chains right so Donald Trump does a
tariff war people stop buying our
soybeans do you think because Kamala
Harris is president suddenly they'll be
like oh we're gonna buy your soybeans
again no they've already found other
people to buy right and they don't know
your back so economically a lot of the
damage will be really really hard to do
okay Seth why are what are your thoughts
on Twitter's new policy that it will
label the tweets of national figures
that break the platform's rules that's a
really [ __ ] hard question that's
that's you know that's a submit that
will break what are the again this this
falls into the category of you know if I
was running Twitter I would not know I I
would curl up into a fetal position and
and hide in the corner I it's the
hardest question in the world to ask
because it's it's you want you want
absolute freedom of speech but at the
same time Twitter's impact and the
impact of Facebook and the impact of
social media is undeniably potent so
there is some regulatory responsibility
to prevent the dissemination of [ __ ]
information but how do you how do you
it's the only the only advice I can give
is to the to the people up top it's just
use your use your brain you know case by
case I don't know I don't know how I
would say to most of the normal people
out there you have to stand up to
Twitter that's what has to happen that's
what liberals are not doing they do it
private the problem is that's easier
said than done because you have the
press that latches on right for the sake
of right
of wait I don't know we got it makes you
a better educated wouldn't be as
susceptible to it I mean this all over
the and I think we also need to be
responsible to push back on just on a
personal level I mean I had a friend
once who post an article on Facebook
that said the Russians are feeding
people in Aleppo why aren't we doing
that well I clicked on the link went to
another link went to another link which
went to Bashar al-assad's website and I
had to call around saying you do realize
you are forwarding the article of a
dictator she didn't know she's oh my god
no idea so if we smell [ __ ] we need
to be community leaders as well as big
and public about it absolutely true it
also is important to turn off your phone
I mean it's a you know it's to remember
that Twitter is not reality and it's
something that I think you saw in the in
the debates you know that if you believe
that the Twitter mob is the real world
you're going to get in trouble and it's
easy enough to turn off your phone and
walk out in there they're they're
bullies do you think it's getting to the
point where this thing that we've
created is getting so powerful and
having such an impact that it's it's
almost like a department of social media
but then what would they do that's right
the only thing I'd say about that Seth
is that when you think about it Twitter
only works in a context where you have
the institutions that allow free speech
to be about the gaiter I'm not I'm not
advocating I'm just asking you know I
saw a member in Iran at the time of the
so-called Green Revolution Twitter was
alive and sparkling and they shut it
down and Harry and will do the same
thing in Hong Kong and in China
safe too so given those choices you know
Twitter is properly protected by liberal
institutions that's more important than
the fact that bad information does get
out and we have to then correct with
good information that's the way the
that's the way system should work and I
can tell you the companies don't accept
any responsibility I was at a conference
in DC for the Atlantic Council and they
were asking about national security on
social media and I won't say which
company but a rep basically said like
hey hey we're just the cart but just
we're not responsible for the eggs
inside there's nothing to do with it I
mean if the other day you're relying you
it's it's at the end of it all comes
down to the conscience of Jack Dorsey
and Mark Zuckerberg and do they want to
do
what's right and I don't and I don't
know what's right I'm you posted a
Facebook the first thing will happen
when you post when you think it was like
2006 right I mean I've only been
recently doing it for this marketing
stuff the first thing you get is boost
post so they're immediately trying to
monetize your post do you thing about
your cat they're like do you want to
send this to 20 more people 30 dollars
you can do it I mean they're about they
are trying to make money based on how
many people use it even if the people
aren't real people they don't care if
they're humans they don't care if it's a
you know troll farm and you know
dubrovsky they don't care they just want
the money and so the problem is saying
they're just a platform they're not no
they're also monetizing us we're not the
customer with a product okay so do you
anticipate that Robert Mahler's public
testimony another story that happened we
didn't mention but it's not going to
happen till July 17 the robert muller
will testify you anticipate his taser
will reveal anything lawmakers don't
already know no can we please Democratic
Party can can America stop outsourcing
the responsibility to contain the
president to robert muller congress if
you want to rein in the president you
have all the power you need it's in the
Constitution stop outsourcing your jobs
to Robert Miller yeah absolutely
absolutely right Detroit but was one
addition I would make look Robert NOLA
did his job he had a very narrow very
precise and realistic conception
nonetheless what did he say in the end I
said I can't indict the guy because I'm
not allowed to and I can't even say I
think he might be indicted right but
nonetheless he was taking it by the
letter of the the office but then he
said and it was like you know trying to
help somebody when they're getting a
question wrong on a test he said if we
could say that he was innocent of
obstruction of justice then we would say
it but we cannot say it here so he's
guilty
yes exactly the same obstruction of
justice and he was trying to go on the
Democratic Congress he's trying to be
such a just a recalled
maybe so but the conclusion is perfectly
clear if you read them all the report
okay what do you think this card said
well you know they did a reading of the
Muller
Church yeah what in New York right a lot
arts with a lot of celebrities Justin
long played call me or no played some
but Justin Timberlake you know just a
long think they couldn't get Justin
Timberlake I promise this you know but
there were some big names here Julie we
Dreyfus was there John Lithgow and they
read the malla report I don't know what
this accomplished we don't know we don't
know what's gonna happen until the votes
are cast and listen there might be a lot
of people that come out of those voting
booths and say listen I was hardcore
right-wing mag
[Laughter]
[Applause]
you
you